[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il paraît qu'il ya une surprise pour moi
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire oui en
fait ils me disent depuis début janvier
on a une surprise pour toi papa papa est
là les chéris j'ai mes fiches je vois à
court de tennis dehors et là j'ai une
fiche où il a marqué la tennis richard
gasquet
voilà tout les et toute l'équipe je vous
aime voir la gauche envers ya ce
week-end il y avait la coupe davis faire
quand il parlera batch et une montée de
shana sans déconner j'ai l'impression
que gdf qui pousse ya un petit joueur
qui vous attend de se confronter à vous
ouais
le joueur de tennis et où ce soir de
tunis et de l'immeuble et l'unef ne
rejoindra menée dans le hall
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
richard on se fait un truc enfin en deux
points gagnants
si tu gagnes franchement demain je sais
que vous faites un truc à l'entraînement
ouais vous mettez tout et doivent faire
des services dfs devient césaire qui me
met cul nu et où les tous les
chroniqueurs dois me viser blessés si tu
gagnes en revanche si je gagne prochain
tournoi est un t-shirt avec by the king
comment la joue comme tu le sais en
impôts alors en droit de connaître les
gars
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
on avait fini par décider
[Musique]
c'est pateychuk également
lors des foires les lieux on était un
joueur exceptionnel ternay 4 à 2,7 du
carton mais que chaque sac et or
[Musique]